التغيرات الميدانيه المرتبطه بالشتاء
القارص دفعت القوات الروسيه لادخال منظومه
دفاع جوي متنقله هذا بهدف حمايه قواتها من
الاستهداف سواء عبر طائرات حربيه او حتى
عبر مسيرات والاهم ان تكون لديها قدره على
العمل في ظروف مناخيه قاسيه وتضاريس صعبه
منظومه تور ام تو دي تي منظومه طور هي
منظومه دفاع جوي تم تجهيزها باحدث طراز
لصواريخ تورا والمعروفه لدى حلف الناتو
بسمه سام خمسه عشر هذه المنظومه هي منظومه
قصيره المدى يمكنها التصدي لطائرات وكذلك
المسيرات وايضا التهديدات الصاروخيه كما
انه لديها الامكانيه لكشف هذه التهديدات
والتعامل معها اثناء الحركه هذه المنظومه
تتكون من رادار لرصد الاهداف واخر لتوجيه
الصاروخ واطلاقه بالاضافه الى 16 صاروخا
تطلق بشكل عمودي
تتكون بطاريه صواريخ طور من اربع منصات
لاطلاق وتوجيه الصواريخ وايضا عربه قياده
وسيطره هذه المنظومه لديها القدره على
التعامل مع 48 هدفا في وقت واحد بمدى يصل
الى 12 كيلومتر وعلى ارتفاع يصل حتى عشره
كيلو مترات وفقا تقارير صحفيه قامت روسيا
بنشر هذه المنظومه في شهر ديسمبر من العام
الماضي في اوكرانيا لكن وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه نشرت مؤخرا مقطع فيديو يظهر
احتراق هذه المنظومه بعد استهدافها بقذيفه
قامت باطلاقها قوات اوكرانيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]